fadi comair bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl france alors on le
disait l'euphrate s'assèchent en syrie
en irak également pourquoi la turquie a
réduit ces derniers jours le débit de ce
fleuve
en fait c'est pas seulement un sujet qui
concerne le frappe et le titre c'est un
sujet qui concerne tous les bassins
transfrontaliers qui sont assujettis aux
changements globaux et qui vont accusé
une diminution de 30% au minimum de leur
débit annuel c'est la raison pour
laquelle la turquie a lancé il ya
quelques années une plateforme de
communication avec les pays qui se situe
à l'aval du bassin de l'euphrate donc
tels que l'irak et la syrie
car l'eau va manquer sûrement et des
crises d'exception vont se répercuter de
plus en plus sur la gestion des bassins
transfrontaliers
la turquie qui envisage de jouer un rôle
pivot dans la reconstruction de la syrie
et de l'irak va s'appuyer sur des
ossatures de coopération c'est ossature
de coopération aussi concerne le droit
international de l'eau qui prône un
partage équitable et une utilisation
raisonnable de l'eau en utilisant le
concept de l'hydre diplôme acier qui est
couple est actuellement au nexus de
lourds de l'énergie et de
l'environnement
ce nexus a été mis par la communauté
internationale avait des objectifs du
développement durable tels que
l'objectif de 6 et 7 donc la turquie n'a
pas le choix que de coopérer avec la
syrie et de coopérer avec l'irak dans le
partage de l'euphrate
est-ce qu'ils avaient déjà des
désaccords solide entre la turquie et la
syrie sur la distribution de volume
d'eau de l'euphrate
tout à fait il y avait des des accords
bilatéraux
or actuellement ce que la turquie
cherche c'est de s'appuyer sur la strate
j 2001 secours pour la prochaine décade
et d'établir plus dans sature de
coopération qui concerne tout d'abord un
échange de données de données hydrique
entre les trois payer ce qui n'est pas
le cas au niveau du bassin du nil
maintenant ce que actuellement l'egypte
prône pour le bassin du nil donc il y à
un échange de données qui actuellement
établi entre la turquie la syrie et
l'irak d un échange de données solides
de données transparent afin qu'ils
puissent tous les trois pays qu'ils
puissent travailler ensemble pour
assurer la survie de des périmètres
d'irrigation la survie alimentaire de
leurs citoyens et aussi assurer l'eau
potable pour les citoyens des grandes
villes telles que bagdad tels que damas
et bien sûr les villes turques
la deuxième procédure de coopération
c'est de trouver un cadre institutionnel
comment assurer une gouvernance pour le
tigre et l'euphrate une gouvernance
commune
cette gouvernance commune pourrait
lancer des projets avec l'aide
internationale afin d'établir des des
technologies innovantes en matière
d'irrigation c'est là où réside le
problème majeur
l'irrigation sur ce bassin consomme à
peu près 70 % de l'eau du bassin de
l'euphrate et du bassin du tigre avec
des technologies innovantes telles que
l'aspersion tels que le goutte à goutte
on pourrait donc diminuer les dépenses
hydrique et a loué le restant à
l'utilisation du secteur de l'eau
potable
la troisième voiture c'est un seuil est
de conclure un accord tripartite entre
la turquie d'un côté la syrie et l'irak
cet accord tripartite serait un accord
qui va pratiquement établir une trame
d'exploitation des barrages qui se
retrouvent qui se trouve à l'amour dont
en turquie et les autres barrages qui se
trouvent en territoire syrien est un
territoire irakien tels que par exemple
le barrage dit l'uso qui dépend
directement du remplissage du
remplissage de l'eau et qui affecte
directement la ville de bagdad en
matière d'eau potable parce que donc
avec ces trois paramètres on pourrait
arriver à concrétiser la stratégie de la
prochaine décade de l'unesco qui prône
pratiquement la sécurité de l'eau dans
un environnement en mutation
mais on entend aussi des raisons
géopolitiques
on entend que la turquie couperet l'eau
de l'euphrate aussi pour faire pression
sur l'administration semi autonome kurde
est ce que c'est le cas je ne pense pas
je ne pense pas parce que actuellement
l'implication des experts dans les
problèmes de sécurité de l'eau s'appuyer
sur des ossatures de coopération jadis
fut le cas donc deux de la gestion
unilatérale des bassins transfrontaliers
tels que le nil tels que le jour d'un
tel que le titre et l'euphrate mais
actuellement comme je vous ai dit il y a
un impact direct des changements globaux
qui vont affecter l'eau des bassins
transfrontaliers
les pays riverains n'ont que le choix de
coopérer ensemble sinon il y aura
directement des conflits hydrique ces
conflits pourrait donc amener les pays à
faire à se faire la guerre une guerre
militaire
c'est la raison pour laquelle à l'unesco
on trône la coopération on prône l'
échange de données afin d'établir des
plans d'adaptation ces plans
d'adaptation concerne les projets
d'irrigation qui se trouve en syrie qui
se trouvent en irak voire même en
turquie et cette eau là pourrait être
partagé de façon équitable entre les
pays riverains
sinon la communauté internationale ne
viendra pas au secours de ces payer pour
renforcer le financement des projets
bilatéraux ou bien les projets
trilatéraux entre les pays riverains
dont actuellement
on est loin du concept hégémonique de
l'eau actuellement les experts
internationaux ainsi que les agences
onusiennes prône le concept de
coopération le concept de l'hydro
diplomatie il n'y a pas d'autre solution
que le dialogue
il n'y a pas d'autre solution que la
diplomatie scientifique
pourquoi la diplomatie scientifique sans
les échanges de données entre les pays
riverains les plans d'adaptation ne
pourront jamais être conçu est établie
afin de sécuriser les populations
c'est la raison pour laquelle l'unesco
est actuellement en train de prôner sa
diplomatie scientifique entre les pays
pour que les pays puissent se retrouver
dans un cadre de communication de
données scientifiques entre eux afin de
pallier aux crises d'exception qui nous
guette le monde est en train de changer
il y aura moins d'eau il y aura plus de
situations d'exception et y aura plus de
pollution comme je le vend actuellement
sur sur votre écran dont il va falloir
travailler afin d'éradiquer ces concepts
hégémonique ces concepts unilatéraux et
renforcer la coopération entre les pays
riverains
merci beaucoup fadi comair pour votre
éclairage orale pelle vous êtes
président du conseil du programme
hydrologique intergouvernementale de
l'unesco est également présidente de
l'association mais durable